all right I'm sure you guys have heard
about this but there was an awful plane
crash in the French Alps the plane sent
out a distress signal at 10 45 and local
time then crash in the mountainous zone
and an altitude of about 2,000 meters
according to the Germanwings CEO it took
the plane eight minutes to descend
before they lost contact with the plane
officials said there were some clouds
but the cloud ceiling was not low and
there did not appear to be turbulence in
a televised statement German Chancellor
Angela Merkel added this is a time an
hour of great sorrow and great grief we
should be thinking about people who have
lost relative and also friends all right
so the story is still breaking but it
does sound like all 150 people on board
did die is it just me or we are there
more of these happening now or is this
just the media or are we just aware of
everything more or what but I feel like
playing like every six months I feel
like we're getting one yeah it does feel
like as a major crash more often but I
think there's probably more planes in
the air I mean statistically it's still
very very safe that's what everyone says
right like that's the thing like they
say in your car going to the market yeah
I mean you know which seems weird
because your up 30 38,000 feet or
whatever but yeah but I think it's just
that there I I'm these planes are
getting older I mean that's part of it
too they said this one's over what was
it like 18 20 years old and they say oh
that's young in this in this field I'm
like really yeah that doesn't know yeah
okay with that yeah dc9 still in the air
I entity flew on a dc9 yeah yeah I don't
know but it's it always uh not the MTV
Veejay Kennedy yeah the press you men
John John F Kennedy gotta cover our
younger viewers yeah well Kennedy
where's about the MTV Kenny work for fox
now so she's by you know flying in
something that's a loss i understand it
right uh really do think these things
are happening more does it feel like
it's happening or anything is a function
of the media it's a function of the
media you know i mean the the classic
line was from the original superman
movie with christopher reeve returns to
somebody in i think he turns to Lois
Lane says you know physically speaking
flying is still safer than any type of
travel yeah but that's like saying well
people who shave get cut and those of
you that don't back down okay so if
somebody says that every 15
minutes right it's the repairing do that
guys think it's a control thing cuz I've
talked about I don't like to fly really
at four years I was drugging myself on
flights I don't do it anymore but now I
just freaked out perhaps the flight but
you think it's a control thing like when
you get in your car even if it's
statistically a higher chance of you
getting hit by on the way the
supermarket that you're at least
controlling a portion of it versus the
plane yes you're in a metal tube hurling
your body through space yeah tens of
thousands of feet above the earth we're
not talking about the car now it is not
help in my case there's nothing in that
that makes a person who likes to have a
little bit of control in their life
comfortable right at all and all I and
all I ever think about is well at least
the pilot is probably got decades of
experience he's flown this playing a lot
and then of course you know they lead
yesterday with the story how that the
pilot had decades of experience yeah I
don't even have that to call me down
anymore in an airplane right oh we are
completely screwed yeah and I took your
first point I I always still drugged
myself on an airplane and by the way
also in the car highly recommend you
know I have like a cyclic no see you
know codeine right there I the visor oh
don't like to drug myself in the
airplane because I worry about if we do
go down I don't know I kind of I don't
want to be drugged for like the last two
minutes of my life I've thought of that
guy and I think if you're going down how
what's the effect of a valium gonna do
on yeah I mean really yeah clearly well
the last time that I measurable I yeah
right you want it to be as stressful as
possible no I bet it's all and it's like
stupid Buddhist mindfulness thing is
like I want to be present during my dad
something I don't know yeah that would
enjoy the air slide that's an idiot um
well I I would go yeah I would be remiss
if we did a story on planes and didn't
just talk a little bit about the media
coverage because it's just it's pretty
horrible and yes we all know that
because of the news cycle every little
thing that happens they they stretch it
out and they bring in they say we're not
going to speculate and then everything
special expect but it's worth it
sometimes seems worse with place doesn't
it and it's I just have to point out CNN
in particular because they're really
addicted to
graphics yeah so they have all these
fancy graphics and I've got enough of an
imagination to picture what it must have
been like for the plane to be going to
sending down now they've got these
special 3d graphics that are showing you
exactly what's happening so for your
first person shooters at home yeah way
along with the girl is rising up in me
and all I could think yesterday was this
is officially plane crash porn yeah I
mean there's no other way to put it
auntie V disgusting it's it's horrific
and I wanted I had to turn my TV is the
case of cereal because the case of Siena
even particularly more bizarre because
they did the months and months on the
other plane crash and the plane was
never found in yet every day they were
saying breaking news as if right the
breaking news is we found out i think it
was their news director had a very large
hard on yesterday yeah donut yes
everywhere he went the worst part for me
was and i watched again this morning now
that there are facts that you know it's
a debris field not the plane pulverized
into a mountain nothing bigger
quote-unquote than the size of a small
car which i thought was going to be some
branded content but they didn't version
a brand of it yeah and then the worst
part of this whole thing is that the guy
explaining the coordination of the
spanish investigation team the german
investigation team and the French mess
is a French guy nothing worse than
having to be taken through a news cycle
from a guy that sounds like he's too
busy to be here it's a plan it crashed
I'm busy getting it is horrible i'm
watching this guy he couldn't look more
bored but put off i'm waiting for my
food they must love you in Paris wow
I've dated the French they're not easy
anyway what do you think of this segment
do you like to fly let us know in the
comments down below please